première dose inoculé pour ces soignants
yéménite sous l'égide de l'unicef et de
l'om est ce la campagne de vaccination
anti qu'ovide a enfin été lancée ce
mardi au yémen
cette première campagne qui durera près
de deux semaines vise dans un premier
temps les professionnels de santé les
personnes âgées ainsi que celles
souffrant de maladies chroniques pour
assurer encourager les yéménites a opté
pour la vaccination
le représentant de l'unicef ainsi que le
porte parole du conseil de transition du
sud ont été parmi les premières recevoir
le vaccin
à présent les vaccins sont disponibles
au yémen une campagne est en cours pour
protéger les populations
il est donc important que les gens
aillent de l'avant se rendre dans les
centres de santé vers les équipes de
vaccination et se fassent vacciner
contre ce virus mortel
il fallait pas pro b nous sommes ravis
de nous joindre aux équipes médicales de
la capitale aden dont le lancement de la
campagne de prévention contre le coït 19
nous avons reçu le vaccin et maintenant
nous appelons les gens à se faire
vacciner aussi pour se protéger et
protéger la société
la campagne débute à aden et va
s'étendre dans les autres gouvernorats
du pays
fin mars le yémen avait reçu 360 mille
doses du vaccin astrazeneca via la
campagne kovacs mise en place par l'eau
et metz à destination des pays à faible
revenu ce pays très touchés par
l'épidémie est aussi ravagé depuis plus
de six ans par une guerre civile entre
forces gouvernementales et rebelles
houthi un conflit qualifié de plus
grande crise humanitaire du monde par le
nul dans ce contexte le yémen doit en
plus de la pandémie faire face à la
malnutrition au manque d'accès à l'eau
potable et aux violences liées au
conflit
à ce jour les autorités ont rapporté
moins de 6000 cas djokovic 19 et près de
1000 140 décès liés au virus
des chiffres très probablement
sous-estimé en raison du peu de tests
effectués du monde de signalement
en particulier dans les zones contrôlées
par la rébellion houti